>> MEIER: Hi there and welcome to The App
Clinic.
I am Dr. Reto Meier.
>> NI-LEWIS: And I'm Dr. Ian Ni-Lewis.
>> MEIER: We are not real doctors.
>> NI-LEWIS: But we are qualified to operate
on Android Apps in several states in US territories.
>> MEIER: The App Clinic is our weekly opportunity
to take a look at some great Android Apps
and talk a little about what we can do to
make them even better.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
So, today, we're looking at travel planning
and booking apps.
I think the idea is, we got the holidays coming
up.
We all go somewhere to get away from our families.
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
Absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: So, let's take a look at the
apps that'll help us plan that.
>> MEIER: Okay.
So, we have a number of apps that we're going
to have to look at today.
Weíre going to start with Worldscope Webcams
4.0.
We've also got Kayak, Hipmunk and TripAdvisor.
So, the idea here is they're all apps which
are going to help you to plan your trip, to
make the bookings for your trip rather than
apps which are going to help you while you
are on holidays.
We are going to look at those later.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
>> MEIER: We have some great suggestions in
the moderator cue for those apps.
Rest assured that we will be checking them
out as well.
>> NI-LEWIS: I think we're going to start
with Worldscope Webcamera which is a little
bit of a twist on what we wanted to see, you
know.
We were thinking more of planning and booking
in terms of as Kayak or Expedia, that sort
of service.
But this one has an interesting twist.
What Worldscope Webcams does is it let's you
check out your destination before you go.
>> MEIER: How nice.
>> NI-LEWIS: So, it'll let you look at webcams
pretty much anywhere.
So, no worries.
No worries.
It's cool.
We were on a streak there.
>> MEIER: A streak of what?
>> NI-LEWIS: One day without an accident.
And just reset that to zero now.
>> MEIER: Yes, it's such a nice intro animation
there.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah, it is.
Well, thank you.
So, what Worldscope does is it let's you take
a look at different webcams across the world
and see what's going on.
So, for instance, here's a Kolonaki where
I used to live.
>> MEIER: That's nice.
>> NI-LEWIS: St. Dagma Square.
I was hoping we don't catch a riot, you know,
no such luck.
>> MEIER: Oh, that's a shame.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
They seemed to be doing all right.
A lot of these webcams just refresh every
few minutes, every hour.
Some of them refresh much more frequently
than that but you can at least get an idea
of what's happening where you want to go.
>> MEIER: That's nice.
>> NI-LEWIS: Like, you sort of one up on Google
street view...
>> MEIER: Yeah, absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...in a way.
You're able to add to favorites with a star.
>> MEIER: Nice one.
>> NI-LEWIS: You're able to refresh the webcam
and there's a huge list of options.
>> MEIER: Okay.
That's so nice.
>> NI-LEWIS: My favorite of course is to show
on map because what I'm really asking is how
close is this webcam to my hotel?
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: We've already been burned that
work, right.
So, let's take a look show on the map.
>> MEIER: Oh, you're using a--open street
maps.
Nice.
>> NI-LEWIS: They certainly are.
>> MEIER: Yeah, it's interesting.
>> NI-LEWIS: It's a little bit rough mostly
because I can see where we are on the map,
but that doesn't really help me.
>> MEIER: Well, no.
>> NI-LEWIS: No.
And if I...
>> MEIER: It's not--it's not necessarily as
specific as you'd like it to be.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
If I'd zoom in, yeah.
So, but in general, you know, you can...
>> MEIER: Oh, Perth.
Nice.
It's show really nice.
>> NI-LEWIS: Absolutely.
>> MEIER: This is my old hometown.
>> NI-LEWIS: Well, yeah, Hillarys Boat Harbour.
They've only a black and white...
>> MEIER: Obviously.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...webcam but that's cool.
>> MEIER: It seems they had video.
>> NI-LEWIS: They had an audio only before
and now they're down all the way up to the
50s.
>> MEIER: Excellent.
You know I thought that we're using a semaphore
flags to explain what the current temperature
and conditions were like.
>> NI-LEWIS: Well, that's how their TCP connection
is.
>> MEIER: Of course, that makes sense.
>> NI-LEWIS: There's a physical link for these
guys.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: It's TCP over some report.
All right.
So, yeah, a very interesting little app.
>> MEIER: Yeah, that's right.
>> NI-LEWIS: Not--you know obviously it does
help you in the travel planning processing
any more than this.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: But not a bad idea.
>> MEIER: Yeah, absolutely.
It would be interesting to see features like
this integrated into other apps or indeed
using intense to allow you to view the webcams
of areas around the hotels you want to book.
So maybe an opportunity for some of the other
apps that we're looking at today to link in
to an app like this.
>> NI-LEWIS: Absolutely.
All right.
Let's go ahead and move on.
>> MEIER: All right.
So, the next step we wanted to look at was
Hipmunk.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yes.
>> MEIER: Have you...
>> NI-LEWIS: You know what...
>> MEIER: Have you ever checked this one out
before?
>> NI-LEWIS: I checked this one out, yeah.
>> MEIER: Did you have a look at the first
few [INDISTINCT] didn't you?
>> NI-LEWIS: I did actually and then we didn't--we
arranged them into an order that would make
sense.
And then we're able to...
>> MEIER: Yeah.
You know that's because, you know, all that
cool movies, growing stuff, that takes time.
>> NI-LEWIS: That took a long time, so long
we don't even have a script for this.
If I was reading off the teleprompter now,
I'd be saying, "Hello everyone.
My name is Reto Meier.
And welcome to this weekend Android Development."
I totally want to get that as a clip.
Okay.
So, Hipmunk.
Hipmunk is more of an all-in-one.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: Now, Hipmunk fully disclosure,
we're friends with the guys that made this
software.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: At least one of them used to
work here.
>> MEIER: Who was that?
>> NI-LEWIS: They're really cool little piece
of software.
Unfortunately, it isn't going to help us a
lot where we are right now which is--let's
see, 77 Saint Georges Terrace and Harris in
Perth.
>> MEIER: Oh, nice.
I have a friend of mine who has a new bar
and restaurant in exactly that location.
>> NI-LEWIS: Is it--is it Lala Rick?
>> MEIER: It might be.
>> NI-LEWIS: That's great.
So, what Hipmunk does is let's you...
>> MEIER: It does?
>> NI-LEWIS: I'll just back out here.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: So this is the first--the first
page of Hipmunk.
It's a dashboard with two items that's trying
not to be a dashboard.
>> MEIER: Uh-huh.
>> NI-LEWIS: And I can either do a hotel search
here.
>> MEIER: It's trying very hard to be a list
rather than a dashboard.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yes.
Hotel search or flight search.
Now, the truth is I'm going to find any hotels
in Perth.
They just don't exist.
>> MEIER: Is that right?
>> NI-LEWIS: But, you know, if I--let's say
that I'm planning a trip.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: And this is actually one thing
that I found a little odd.
I felt like the first thing I wanted in an
application like this was not to actually
see my location.
But, you know, let's--weíll go over that
a little bit more.
So, let's--the trip that I want to take is
to Venice.
Oh, not...
>> MEIER: Venice, Florida?
>> NI-LEWIS: ...Venice, Florida.
Venice, Italy.
Yeah.
>> MEIER: It didn't seem to work.
>> NI-LEWIS: No.
Let's--I give up.
Let's go to Venice, Florida or Valencia of
Venezuela.
Apparently...
>> MEIER: That's pretty much the same thing.
>> NI-LEWIS: You know when I travel I'm easy.
Okay.
Now, it's got a little progress bar down there.
And notice it's filling in all the hotels
that I can find that fit my definition of
what I wanted.
>> MEIER: Okay.
>> NI-LEWIS: And you can filter using the
settings.
Log in and you can get a heat map to let you
know what's good and bad in terms of price.
You can also do a flight search.
And their flight search that's apparently--okay,
Perth to Honolulu.
That is perfect.
We'll go ahead and do that.
>> MEIER: That's a really cheap flight too.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> MEIER: Yeah, apparently.
>> NI-LEWIS: Awesome.
All right.
They do take awhile but I hope we can get
to this screen in a reasonable amount of time
because they have probably the best flight
search screen I've ever seen.
>> MEIER: Oh, there you go.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
So...
>> MEIER: Look at them.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...they allow you to search by
different categories, you know, price and
when you depart and when you arrive but it
also let you sort by this thing called agony.
I think that's the coolest thing in the world.
>> MEIER: That's nice.
>> NI-LEWIS: It's a combination of the departure
and arrival time, the total time of the flight,
how bad your seat is and a bunch of other
things.
And, it also let's you see...
>> MEIER: Oh, you can zoom in the...
>> NI-LEWIS: ...on the calendar.
Yeah.
>> MEIER: Okay.
>> NI-LEWIS: Now, the nice thing--I think
we don't have it set up here but we--this
will actually integrate with your calendar.
So, if you have events...
>> MEIER: That's [INDISTINCT]
>> NI-LEWIS: ...you know, for instance...
>> MEIER: You can see whether you're going
to make it there in time and make sure that
you leave after a reasonable period after
your last meeting.
>> NI-LEWIS: Exactly.
Like, for instance, it might say, "Oh here,
we've got the, you know, Android Developers
weekly."
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: And I would say, "Well, I don't
care about that."
So, you know we're at and there we go.
And also, it color codes the airlines but
I haven't figure it out yet.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: I was hoping at first that it
would be frequent flight per hour.
>> MEIER: Okay.
Always.
Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> MEIER: That's nice.
>> NI-LEWIS: And it's not...
>> MEIER: I think it's actually based on the
color scheme of the airline because Cathay
Pacific is that olive green, Emirates is that
sort of red color, so that could be it.
Japan Airlines, I don't know if they're gray.
I don't know.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> MEIER: It looks like it could be basing
on something like that.
>> NI-LEWIS: Okay.
Anyway just a really cool thing.
It also...
>> MEIER: That's great.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...marks your flights as to whether
they have Wifi or not and couple of other
convenient little things.
>> MEIER: Nice.
>> NI-LEWIS: So, that's cool.
All right.
Let's go ahead and move on and quickly go
over Kayak.
So, Kayak is one of a family of apps that--I
think are really decided gateway to the web
service.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: They're all very similar but
I think it's pretty well done.
You have the opportunity to search for hotels
and, you know, check in with your check in
and check out time.
You can search your flights and you can also
search any number of other things...
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...including your airport information,
not seat information.
I'm surprised about that...
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
That's unfortunate.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...or I might've just missed
it.
>> MEIER: You shouldn't.
>> NI-LEWIS: But also, you can even do you
packing list here.
>> MEIER: Oh, nice.
>> NI-LEWIS: So, sort of the...
>> MEIER: So, sort of the full service model
of traveling and booking plan.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
It's an all-in-one flight planner.
>> MEIER: Nice.
>> NI-LEWIS: And also, let's take a look at
the apps that you looked at Reto.
>> MEIER: Sure.
I looked at a couple this morning when I wasn't
messing around in the clinic.
There's two apps.
One, is a FastBooking and the other TripAdvisor.
So, we're going to have to look at FastBooking
first which is this app here.
So, I can hit the icon.
So, this is a sort of based primary around
just the booking part of the app.
And much like, you know, most of the other
apps we're looking at--you know you have that
ability to, you know, basically be able to
specify your details and find out if there
are hotels available.
So, this is actually available in the US.
It's a European app.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: But I thought, you know, why not
have a look.
So, one of the things which struck me immediately
upon looking at this app is that you sort
of end up straight in this page where you're,
you know, ready to book your hotels.
There's no real--you know there's no additional
features, there's no flights.
It's really just hotel bookings.
If we search around May, I'm going to suspect
that its not going to work so I'm going to
put in--let's put in Venice because, we know,
we got to go there last time.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> MEIER: And search.
>> NI-LEWIS: You know what's odd I have occasions
only wanted exactly this.
Just something that we take to my current
location and tell me what hotel we're going
to route.
>> MEIER: Which one escaped, yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: But that was only when I was
like backpacking around the world that calls
you--I mean you really got to be in an odd
position...
>> MEIER: Yeah, to...
>> NI-LEWIS: ...to want to use that feature.
>> MEIER: Well, you know, that being said
its not--it's not the most ridiculous.
You know, I know that there has been in occasions
in my past where I haven's had a backpack,
but had still been looking for somewhere.
Sort of last minute.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
Absolutely, you know, when you--when you read
the current heat row and decide to drive up
to Scotland to visit distilleries.
Whenever you're tired you want to find out...
>> MEIER: You want to just find...
>> NI-LEWIS: ...where the nearest hotel is.
Absolutely.
>> MEIER: ...something near by.
Exactly, so you go through and it's got the
usual things that you'd expect from a hotel
booking app.
You got descriptions, star ratings.
Find out about the rooms, galleries reviews.
All those sort of things, so itís a fully
featured hotel booking app, but doesn't really
go beyond that.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
It certainly has really nice hotel booking
features--I mean...
>> MEIER: Oh, absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...I donít think any other app
have these galleries.
I guess it's really...
>> MEIER: No.
This is very true.
They're really--you know, gone that extra
step I think to make sure that you can see
exactly what is you are going to be getting.
>> NI-LEWIS: Now, Rachel and I have travel
a lot, right--I mean, well you've--we've been
around the world.
I--and I've done a lot of booking.
And mostly on websites and it will say I usually
have three or four tabs open.
One is for the flights to try and figure out
what the best times are.
Maybe airlines to figure out which alliance
they belong to or how many miles I'm going
to get.
I'll probably have seat SeatGuru opened, so
I can see, you know, if I'm getting a seat
near the bathroom or not.
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: And I'll also have the individual
hotel pages open to try and find out what
their rooms are like, what their policies
are like, so to me an all in one travel app
will be Godsend.
>> MEIER: Yeah, absolutely.
Absolutely and we have to do this a lot.
And often when are traveling it's for some
industry conference.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: CES and Google Congress and so,
you know, you really--in this situation when
there aren't a lot of rooms.
A lot of people are coming at the same time
and you--having to do this for work, so its
not pleasure.
You are not trying to--you know, you are not
enjoying the process of finding a place to
stay.
You just...
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
>> MEIER: ...have all the information in one
place and make sure its going to be as pleasant
as you can it be.
>> NI-LEWIS: Exactly.
We actually came up with some prescriptions
for a good travel app but before we get to
them lets take a look to our last app.
>> MEIER: Yeah, we got one more app to look
at which is Trip it--oh, sorry.
Not trip it.
TripAdvisor.
I like...
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
>> MEIER: ...any app which has trip at the
beginning of it.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah, exactly.
>> MEIER: So, TripAdvisor is--TripAdvisor
is great.
So, I use this website a lot and my wife specially
uses it a lot to help plan our holidays.
And so this is getting a little closer to
this full service model.
You can see here that we've got hotels, restaurants,
things to do, flight's, [INDISTINCT] the whole
sort of things.
So, even you know, from booking the hotels
to begin with before you start your travel.
Let's go with current location.
I think that what it does by default.
So, now this is something that I did want
to--did want to talk about really briefly.
It really wants me to write the app.
I hate--I hate this.
I hate this feature.
I hate people telling me, you know, please
validate me.
Tell me how awesome I am.
If I like the app I will go and give it a
good review.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
I think it's...
>> MEIER: This make me want to give it a bad...
>> NI-LEWIS: It feels a little desperate...
>> MEIER: Really it does.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...but you know, honestly I think
that we may feel that way just because we
look at so many apps.
>> MEIER: I guess but--I mean, its--to me
it's breaking the magic, right?
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: So, it's like we've talk about this
a lot.
And sort of app that I want to use doesn't
make me think about the fact that it's not
an app, you know.
Its just going to be a part of the phone something
that I'm always going to have installed in
any device that I have.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
It's true.
I don't think you'd ever get into you Bentley
and have your Bentley say, "Hey.
Do you like driving this car?"
Maybe you like to talk about it on Facebook."
>> MEIER: Tell your friends how much you love
driving your Bentley.
Itís a little desperate.
Itís a little needy and in this...
>> NI-LEWIS: Absolutely.
>> MEIER: In this app in particular if I hit
back now then--okay, it's gone.
It knows that I say no but actually you'll
find that as we continue to navigate through
it is going to pop up again and again.
>> NI-LEWIS: Oh.
>> MEIER: Which is, you know, I'm switching.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
I think the only way that I've been happy
with that is if I see that as a single menu
option in the overflow.
>> MEIER: Exactly.
>> NI-LEWIS: You know, oh, yeah right.
I was going to rate that app, okay.
You know and for some reason I am completely
clueless about how to launch Google Play.
>> MEIER: I installed the app in Google Play.
And used the reviews to decide whether I wanted
it but I still can't figure out how to review
it.
Okay, then itís a useful thing.
>> NI-LEWIS: All right.
Sure.
>> MEIER: But we will stop beating on that
horse.
So, the real key here is that it has all of
the TripAdvisor stuff in here.
So, it's got huge number of traveler reviews
and these are really valuable reviews which
a lot of people put a lot of time and effort
into, you know, providing that information.
There's photos from the--from people who've
actually stayed in these places.
All done with nice--you know, clear pages
so you can see exactly what you are looking
at.
It's quite nice.
>> NI-LEWIS: Although we can't really rate
the content so much when we are talking about
the Android App because a lot of great services
exist on the web.
>> MEIER: Yes.
That is true.
>> NI-LEWIS: And not all of them have great
Android Apps to go along with that...
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...great content.
>> MEIER: Yes.
No, absolutely.
And then this is a really good example of
tying to take something what you already have
this great content and leveraging on what
it is really rapidly becoming the way that
people access their information.
And I think the things that I travel specially
so, because you can seat in your couch with
your Nexus 7 and flick through all these hotels.
It can be a nice experience.
>> NI-LEWIS: Absolutely--I mean, the one thing
that strikes me immediately when I look this
app is, "Wow.
I think everyone on the design team is probably
carrying a phone by a different manufacturer."
>> MEIER: Yes.
That definitely does seem to be the case.
And will go into a little more detail about
the specifics around some of the designs issues
but you can straight away see, you know, we've
got these kind of weird looking tabs, the
two small buttons here.
We got the action bar which is nice but then
we are not using sort of standard [INDISTINCT]
just to control the navigation but...
>> NI-LEWIS: [INDISTINCT] levels.
>> MEIER: [INDISTINCT] I like its--again we
happened to be in my hometown of Perth at
the number six attraction and the best recommendation
here is the Swan River.
Itís a river.
>> NI-LEWIS: I like rivers.
>> MEIER: Rivers are great and [INDISTINCT]
but I guess that's number 97 but anyway I
do [INDISTINCT] so, we got things to see,
places to eat, places to stay.
All sort of put that--put there for you to
observe which is nice.
You know, its give you that ability to be
able to create your entire trip all in one
place.
Cool.
Nice.
>> NI-LEWIS: All right.
So, those are the apps that we are looking
at today.
Let's go in a little deeper.
Open them up and...
>> MEIER: Absolutely, yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...see what's going on.
>> MEIER: Let's really get in there and perform
a clinic.
So...
>> NI-LEWIS: That's great.
>> MEIER: We've put together some prescriptions
and I know you spent a little bit more time
with the apps this week than I have Ian.
So, why don't you tell the folks what does
it take to make a great travel booking and
planning app?
>> NI-LEWIS: Well, first as always you need
to be consistent with the Android design guide.
Why is that important because we want to have
a consistent experience and users always know
how to do what they want to do.
Now remember last week we talked about camera
apps and we said that they should be pretty
and consistent.
In this case of course you want it to be pretty
but they don't need to be artistic.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: More than anything else they
need to be useful and consistent and probably
also branded.
>> MEIER: Yeah, absolutely.
You want to make sure people know what they
are using and I think one thing which is consistent
here, you know, we are talking about particularly
when it comes to hotels and tourist attractions
to make good use of photos.
You know, that's really was going to sell
people on the destinations is being able to
see that.
So, we want to see nice big rich images.
>> NI-LEWIS: Absolutely.
Now travel app just need to be location aware.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: Most apps do but certainly--no,
when you're--when you are traveling obviously
you are almost always going to be starting
from your current location somewhere you like.
It should integrate with my digital life and
I can't over emphasize this.
This is really, really important to me.
I want to make sure that the tools that I
used to keep track of my life like calendar,
like Google+ or Facebook or Twitter are integrated
into this tool so that my travel plans and
my real life--my regular life can fit together.
And, you know, I mean maybe this is just me,
but I'm honestly sometimes forgotten that
I was going to go to China until the last
minute.
>> MEIER: Wait, is that today?
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
Its like I would literally make plans.
Like, oh yeah, I can totally go out with you
on Tuesday night.
Oh, yeah, I'm going to be in China.
We want something to plans your trip.
A trip is not just a flight.
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: It's a flight, a hotel.
It's transportation through and from the hotel.
It's...
>> MEIER: The things to do...
>> NI-LEWIS: Random tourist [INDISTINCT] that
my wife likes and finally we want something
that's gong to let me do the entire set of
transaction by everything related at a trip
on the device.
I don't want to have to go to a website.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: I definitely don't want to pop
up a browser window if possible.
>> MEIER: No.
And I don't want to have to save something
and then look into my account on a computer
to be able to complete things.
You know, I just want to be able to do everything
right from whatever device I'm using.
>> NI-LEWIS: So, let's keep those in mind
to take a look at some of this apps.
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
And while we do that I want to remind folks
that we have produce a [INDISTINCT].
Keeping an eye on our YouTube and Google+
events.
So, if you have any questions or comments
about the apps that we are looking at maybe
ways in which, you know--what are the prescriptions
you guys think it takes to make a great app?
Do let us know and we will try and answer
those questions as well.
>> NI-LEWIS: Absolutely.
Producers Scott, do we have anything interesting
on the comments stream right now?
>> I'm not seeing a whole lot of interaction.
>> NI-LEWIS: Shame on you.
Shame on you viewers.
Talk to producer Scott.
He's lonely.
>> MEIER: He's very lonely.
He's just checking his email.
His got this frown on his face.
>> Yeah.
I really don't know what you guys are talking
about.
>> NI-LEWIS: It's hard to be Scott.
He just moved down here from Seattle and the
sun is killing him.
>> MEIER: It's foggy and overcast in Mountain
View today, but even still.
>> NI-LEWIS: Even still the son is killing
him.
And this doesnít look like September.
It looks like late July.
All right.
>> MEIER: Let's put some...
>> NI-LEWIS: Let's go ahead and take a look
at.
>> MEIER: Let's do that.
Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
Take a little deeper look at starting with
Worldscope.
Now, this is going to be a quick one because...
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: There's not lot to this app.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: But I did have some issues with
not just our prescription for a travel app
which don't necessarily apply to this particular
app.
>> MEIER: Cool.
>> NI-LEWIS: But with the UI the first problem
that I had is that this area here it looks
like a view pager, right?
>> MEIER: It does.
Yeah, you should be able to fling that around.
>> NI-LEWIS: No.
>> MEIER: No.
>> NI-LEWIS: However, this is.
So you've got the tabs...
>> MEIER: Oh, okay.
So, the tabs are most likeable.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
Now, I think they may have done that because
when you get to the map which is zoomed way,
way out.
>> MEIER: Way out.
>> NI-LEWIS: It's a little bit difficult to
operate the size of view page and that's understandable
but...
>> MEIER: The view size.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...I don't feel like that's necessarily
an excuse for making it completely broken
everywhere else.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
I mean there are ways that you can sort of
do an edge swipe as well so you can still
have a view page a type functionality while
you still got a full screen, a multi-pen...
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: You know.
>> NI-LEWIS: It also bothered me that the
search tab doesn't actually search.
It's just the map view.
>> MEIER: Oh, so it's more browse like browse
file.
Well, it's just browse.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
And then I have to do...
>> MEIER: Get search.
>> NI-LEWIS: I have to actually.
Now, they are doing the regular search bar
in the action bar so that's very, very nice.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
They've done that the nice--the right way
which is nice to see and you got your appropriate
app for [INDISTINCT] instead to escape out
of it which is nice to see.
You can see here--one thing that I noticed
was that we're actually cutting of the name
of the app while were in portrait mode.
So it seems like this might be an opportunity
to drop the name completely and just stick
with the logo rather than having in abbreviated
name which just kind of makes it look squished.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
You also might give some serious thought to
completely getting rid of these tabs and making
those a navigation drop down.
So, obviously you've decided that you don't
want view put-- view page activities and if
you don't want to view pager then being able
to just tap on the app icon, have a drop down
navigation...
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...is going to be just as fast,
pretty much just discoverable and you get
the screen really [INDISTINCT].
>> MEIER: And if I'm not mistaken I believe
that if you actually use the standard action
bar tabs it will switch between having a drop
navigation in portrait mode and if you've
got space, so at landscape mode or on tablets
it actually switched to a tab layout instead.
>> NI-LEWIS: Very nice.
>> MEIER: Get it for free.
>> NI-LEWIS: And that would be very cool.
And I mentioned before to that once you're
on this map zooming in is not particularly
efficient.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: And if you already know where
you want to go being able to zoom in on the
specific location that you wanted is not impossible.
>> MEIER: Right.
>> NI-LEWIS: The best way I found to that
is to actually tap this key a little places
key and that will show you things you can
zoom in on.
>> MEIER: Got you.
And then you can just keep hitting that tab
until you're...
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
And readjusting and just feeling frustrated
the whole time.
>> MEIER: Right.
>> NI-LEWIS: This is something where honestly
it might be better to just integrate with
nice maps that--API or at least give some
thought to how you would zoom in directly.
I actually thought this button might do it
but...
>> MEIER: It zooms out.
>> NI-LEWIS: It actually does exactly the
opposite of what I wanted.
>> MEIER: That's interesting.
As well, I look that icon on the first thing
I think is a full screen like I expected to
just, you know, go full screen...
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
>> MEIER: ...and it doesn't.
So, that's a little bit of confusing.
>> NI-LEWIS: So, how can I zoom?
Well, I have to actually select it of a menu
which...
>> MEIER: Oh, it's on the streets.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...wow.
Yeah.
>> MEIER: Okay.
>> NI-LEWIS.
1995 call they want your model of user interaction
back.
>> MEIER: Yes, that's definitely something
you want to have front and center.
That ability to really determine but it's--it's
an interesting app and I think, you know,
they've done something kind of cool there.
>> NI-LEWIS: You know.
So, the scores here are--aren't fair at all.
We score based on traveling booking as oppose
to the certain niche app and let's take a
look at what we've got here.
>> MEIER: I rather suspect that the scores
are going to come in the end.
>> NI-LEWIS: Scores are at the end.
We've...
>> MEIER: Yeah.
Now, I can see where we were going now.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> MEIER: In fusion, the scores will go after
we've discussed the app.
>> NI-LEWIS: All right.
>> MEIER: For now, we're going to bump bounce
through each of the apps first and then go
back and have a look how we each of them scored
on our...
>> NI-LEWIS: Perfect.
>> MEIER: ...prescriptions.
>> NI-LEWIS: All right.
>> MEIER: So, the next app.
Let's bring up Kayak and dig a little deeper
there as well.
>> NI-LEWIS: Quite right.
Did we want to bring up Kayak or did you want
to bring Hipmunk?
>> MEIER: Hipmunk.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-huh.
>> MEIER: I'm looking at next slide instead
of current slide.
>> NI-LEWIS: I am absolutely not the only
one making mistakes today.
>> MEIER: No.
>> NI-LEWIS: Okay.
Hipmunk, okay.
First thing they really did make some efforts
to be more Androidy.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: Unfortunately, some of those
efforts felt a little misguided.
>> MEIER: Yup.
>> NI-LEWIS: For instance, it was actually
in the--they said oh, yeah we tried to make
it more Androidy by squaring off a corner
so they're not rounded.
>> MEIER: It shows it's Androidy.
I can see that.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
You know, what we don't have an entire hour
to discuss that so let's just--let's just
point out that--these buttons down here in
the corner should almost certainly be on a
action bar.
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
I mean they are actions, right?
>> NI-LEWIS: They are.
Now, the icons here look like more or less
standard like Android icons.
They don't do the same thing.
>> MEIER: Okay.
>> NI-LEWIS: The--this looks like settings
right down here.
>> MEIER: Looks like settings.
>> NI-LEWIS.
No, it is filter.
>> MEIER: Oh.
>> NI-LEWIS: There is a filter icon.
>> MEIER: There's a filer icon.
Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: Settings should actually take
you to settings.
>> MEIER: That should point out as well we
don't want settings to be an action.
Which probably leave you [INDISTINCT]
>> NI-LEWIS: Exactly.
>> MEIER: There was an [INDISTINCT]
>> NI-LEWIS: Unless settings is absolutely
crucial for your application.
>> MEIER: This is nice.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah, yeah.
>> MEIER: So, the [INDISTINCT] map is kind
of awesome.
>> NI-LEWIS: Very cool.
Yeah.
Now, this is the list icon.
It's a little confusing but it will allow
you to view the hotels by list.
>> MEIER: Okay.
>> NI-LEWIS: Here's the problem.
It will pop out at the host.
>> MEIER: Search first and tap to view this
list of hotels.
>> NI-LEWIS: Please do not press this button
again.
So, this is a scolding toast.
>> MEIER: Yeah, it is.
>> NI-LEWIS: You're scolding...
>> MEIER: he's done the wrong the thing.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
Oops.
>> MEIER: You're holding it wrong.
>> NI-LEWIS: Instead, I mean you're popping
up the toast to tell them what to do.
Why don't you just do it?
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: Now, you're never not looking
at a map in this cell.
>> MEIER: This is true.
I noticed that when I was sort of playing
around with the app earlier.
I'm trying to find, you know, is there a sort
of a step back from that and it's not--it's
all map that and which is kind of a nice idea
you have this sort of reach interface you
can see exactly way you're looking the way
you can stay.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yup.
Now...
>> MEIER: I really want you to [INDISTINCT]
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
>> MEIER: As far on a...
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
So, if I type in Venice it all will be...
>> MEIER: So this is something...
>> NI-LEWIS: It still wants me to go to Florida.
Now, if I dismiss this, dismiss the keyboard
and say search then it works.
>> MEIER: Interesting.
>> NI-LEWIS: Okay.
Now, while it's working we can complain a
little bit about the progress bar.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: So, the progress bar is completely
running.
It doesnít look like any progress bar that
exists in Android at all.
And it's not clear exactly what I'm going
to do with.
I guess the access for cancel--I mean that's
make sense.
>> MEIER: Usually the cancel.
>> NI-LEWIS: You know, that's nice but it's
down at the very bottom of the screen...
>> MEIER: Yeah.
Small...
>> NI-LEWIS: ...will be very...
>> MEIER: ...soft touch.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...yeah, very small touch target
would be very easy to accidentally hit the
home key.
I'm not loving yet.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
Now, it just kind of looks tact on.
You know, I really much prefer to see something
like a refreshing image in the action bar
something to show that progress is something
much like you would see if you hit refresh
on Gmail or something like that.
>> NI-LEWIS: Now, once I'm there it's very
cool.
I can toggle all the heat maps and I can see
what kind of vice is in the area.
Oh, that's wrong.
Venice is full of vice everywhere and I don't
where they count their vice.
>> MEIER: That's a very good question.
Is it location specific or does it figure
out the way you're on now and then...
>> NI-LEWIS: It's a good question.
I think they're selling unrolled something
that we can't talk about on TV.
Okay.
So, really nice features but the UI could
use some work.
Now, once I actually get in here, you know,
we've got the nice stuff and it's says no,
we've got...
>> MEIER: And it even got a TripAdvisor reviews
and in fact.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
Yeah, yeah, so I like that.
That's nice.
It would maybe like a few more pictures...
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: You can see they've a--they done
some weird things.
It's like they've got their own...
>> MEIER: Oh, that's not quite.
>> NI-LEWIS: You see how that bounces around.
>> MEIER: Not quite right.
Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: So, it's cool.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: I mean, you know, somebody obviously
spends some time with that, they certainly
didnít make it worse.
My only concern is that when you write your
own unless it's doing something that is incredibly
important to your app you sort of opening
yourself up for some real problems later on.
Sure, you know, we love the bouncy feel now
but later on if the Android Platform goes
in a different direction everyone else is
going to pick up that updated field and you're
going to be stock with this thing that is
going to end up feeling updated.
>> MEIER: So, there's no problem in taking
some of the built in framework components
in modifying them.
Having--adding a little bit if your own spice
to it, but it something you want to do carefully
knowing that at anytime you could run the
risk of starting to look aged and old.
>> NI-LEWIS: It's also very difficult to get
back to were you where.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
I noticed that the navigation isn't quite
right.
>> NI-LEWIS: It's really easy to back out
of something.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: In fact they have multiple ways
to back out of a screen including the up affordance
and an action button and the back button.
But then to get back into that hotel search
you got to research.
>> MEIER: You do the whole thing.
>> NI-LEWIS: What's, you know, it's a pain.
>> MEIER: It's--one of the things which I--which
I noticed about this app, and it's something
I've seen quite a lot of, is sort of, you
navigate into something which has a view pager
and then that view pager has an entirely different
context.
So it's like this is about the hotel.
This is reviews.
As you're swiping through it makes sense but
you kind of feel like you're navigating through
the app.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: It's sort of a totally different
UI.
And then I often find myself then hitting
back to then, you know, go back to say the
previous, you know, the previous view pager
which isn't the behavior that should happen.
But then I find myself back here, back here
at the--at the search screen and then I have
to do the whole thing again.
I have wait for it to complete and so you
kind want a way to prevent that accidental
back behavior from really ruining your day.
>> NI-LEWIS: And what's even worse is that
here--I'm going through exactly the same dance
that I had to go through last time.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: Which is extremely disturbing
considering that if I go all the way back
here and tried a flight search, it has a recentÖ
>> MEIER: It doesÖ
>> NI-LEWIS: Ösearches option.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: So why doesnít it have a recent
searches option for hotels?
I'm actually more likely to need thatÖ
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: Ösince it's not all composed
because I haven't necessarily decided where
I'm going to stay or which particular suburbÖ
>> MEIER: Sure.
>> NI-LEWIS: ÖI'm going to be in.
I mean I do a lot of different hotelÖ
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: Ösearches andÖ
>> MEIER: And typicallyÖ
>> NI-LEWIS: ÖI want to go back to them.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
Typically you're going to do, you know, several
different hotel searches in different areas.
You want to be able to compare them easily
and I think that's really thing you want to
be able to do really quickly is have this
list of hotels that you're considering and
just be able to click through them and thenÖ
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> MEIER: Öreview them all.
>> NI-LEWIS: Now, notice it s location aware,
so it found outÖ
>> MEIER: Yes.
>> NI-LEWIS: Öyou know, where we're at and
I think, you know, we're going to Honolulu
sure.
No, no, no.
I think we're going to Venice.
Now, again.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
See, interesting so nowÖ
>> NI-LEWIS: This is the most interestingÖ
>> MEIER: Öa little bit [INDISTINCT]
>> NI-LEWIS: Ömatch that I've seen actually.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: Okay.
You know what, screw Venice.
We're going toÖ
>> MEIER: Going to Athens.
>> NI-LEWIS: ÖAthens.
>> MEIER: Nice.
>> NI-LEWIS: That's right.
Now, this is the part I do really like.
This is a good UI.
I can--you know, I'm going to go over Thanksgiving.
>> MEIER: Nice.
>> NI-LEWIS: No better time to go to Athens.
>> MEIER: Now, the interesting thing here.
So I looked at this app a little while ago
and you've correctly, you know, done your
from and to dates.
I made the mistake the first time and I'm
not sure if it will work, of just pressing
the date I was going to leave and then hitting
done.
>> NI-LEWIS: And that will give you a one-way
flight.
>> MEIER: And that gives me one-way flight
and I couldn't, for the life of me, figure
out how to turn a one-way flight into a return
flight until someone had the good sense to
just, you know, click a second date.
>> NI-LEWIS: Exactly.
So it's a really easy to use interface.
It's wonderful but it's not discoverable.
>> MEIER: Exactly.
So that's something you want to consider is,
you know, chances are in most cases, people
are looking for a return flight.
And so you want to make really obvious if
there--if anyone selected one date that this
going to result in a one-way and perhaps they
should click a return date if they want to
have a return.
>> NI-LEWIS: Now, here is an example of a
case where they--they may not have completely
thought through their layout because as you
can see over here.
The calendar is very nicely formatted.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: Most of the really important
data has been put in to, you know, bold fonts
that are a good size and good readability
for the screen.
But then you've got three areas, the two buttons
and this little area up here that says tap
down to continue, it is just sort of taking
up space.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: Telling me something that I'm
sure I already knew.
And those are in a tiny and almost illegible
font.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
You're right.
>> NI-LEWIS: I think a lot of this comes from
making some assumptions about the devices
that you program on.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: Especially when it comes to screen
size and density.
Remember that some screens are relatively
small but incredibly dense.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: And if you're not thinking about
that sort of HD density then you're going
to have a bad time.
>> MEIER: And actually, while you had that
screen back upÖ
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: Öyou knowÖ
>> NI-LEWIS: I'm going to do the search because
it's going toÖ
>> MEIER: It just takes a little while.
>> NI-LEWIS: Ötake a while, yeah.
>> MEIER: So one of the interesting things
I noted is when you've got that calendar view
up, it comes up as a dialog.
Now, I know why it comes up as a dialog, it's
because if you're on the web and you need
to choose a calendar entry, you want to put
it in a dialog.
You want to put a little screen which comes
up rather than having the entire display taken
up with it.
On your phone, that was already covering 90%
of the screen, why not just make it a full
screen activity and have it behave in that
same way.
I have it done affordance at the top, so that
you can just continue that way rather than
having a sort of weird pop dialog which doesn't
really work.
I think in most cases on a mobile device.
>> NI-LEWIS: That's true.
It's harder to write code that way.
It's a little harder to manage the activity
stack and it doesn't buy you anything does
it?
Because there'sÖ
>> MEIER: No.
You donítÖ
>> NI-LEWIS: Önothing you can [INDISTINCT]
>> MEIER: Öget anything extra for it.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
So the other thing too is that if you put
it in a full screen activity then all of the
navigation has sort of been done for you by
the framework.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: Good example of this would be
the alarm clock app, where you also have to
set a, you know, date and time.
And they just have, you know, full screen
and done.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: At least they do now, I think.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: Okay.
I think they didn't before actually.
>> MEIER: Indeed.
>> NI-LEWIS: I donít know.
>> MEIER: I think there use to be more of
those pop ups but it'sÖ
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: Öa trend that we seeing more and
more of in mobiles, sort of design.
It's getting rid of dialogs in all places
and having full screen activities whenever
you can.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
Now, this is great.
This is--it's showing me, you know, where
I can go.
I mean, so if I do Cathay I'm going to have
a layover in Hong Kong which is great.
Cathay isÖ
>> MEIER: Sure.
Cathay is nice.
>> NI-LEWIS: Öalways take that.
>> MEIER: Emirates is nice too.
>> NI-LEWIS: First thing, you know, then you--you
know, oh yeah.
Well, I've never been able to take Emirates,
you know why?
>> MEIER: Why is that?
>> NI-LEWIS: I'm not special.
>> MEIER: Oh.
>> NI-LEWIS: Based in the U.S.
You'll get used to it.
>> MEIER: This is great.
>> NI-LEWIS: You don't get any good service
from the U.S.
>> MEIER: Well, you know, I moved here and
suddenly like all of the good airlines; Singapore,
Emirates, Cathay, Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: No.
Not so much.
>> MEIER: And New Zealand is like the best
way to get back home.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> MEIER: I'm not sure what that says, but
it's nothing good.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
Just don't fly Northwest that's all I'm saying.
Anyway so layover in Zurich, and then, you
know, et cetera, et cetera.
So that's some nice stuff and it's--again
it's listed by agony soÖ
>> MEIER: But this is--this a really nice
display.
>> NI-LEWIS: I can also always take that list
the price.
>> MEIER: I really like what they're showing
here.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: It feels like the actual way that
they've implemented the layout here isn't
quite as nice as it could be.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: You know, they've something which
is incredibly useful.
I mean this is I think one of real selling
points of the app, is just how useful the
screen is but, you know, if you look at things
like the, you know, the prices along--prices
along the left here.
That it all feels a little bit cramped in.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: There's not enough spacing around
the elements.
Each of the line items seems just a little
bit too little.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> MEIER: Like the rows need to just be a
little bit higher, I think.
You know, sort of 48 pixel rhythm, you know,
follow the sort of design guideline ideas
that we have there.
And that will just make it feel a little bit
more natural.
Here even though it's not--it feels cramped.
You know, some of the fonts are a bit too
small.
>> NI-LEWIS: That's true.
>> MEIER: Some of the touch targets are a
little bit too small.
It just feels like.
>> NI-LEWIS: We'll to be fair, they are--they
are trying to present a lot of information.
>> MEIER: Absolutely, absolutely.
That should count.
>> NI-LEWIS: And in their defense they do
have some really good zooming.
>> MEIER: Yes,
>> NI-LEWIS: Now, you can see that as they
zoom, it actually feels very intuitive.
You know, things are getting bigger but they're
getting bigger in ways that are useful to
me that arenít exactly what I would get if
it was just a naive zoom.
You know, you can see these things resizing
in more of a smart way.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: So overall I like it.
The one things I would like is a few more
options here to filter, buy things like frequent
flyer miles.
Because if you're going--even if you only
take one trip a year, if it's this long, you
want to figure out some frequent flyer things.
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: Okay.
So nice app, few issues.
Let's go ahead and take a look Kayak shall
we?
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: All right.
So Kayak I thought was not really a great
design from the UI standpoint, it certainly
doesn't feel at all like an Android app when
you get into it for the first time.
There's no action bar.
There's this notifications button down here
that's way, way too small.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: And it's down at the bottom where
I'm going to probably, you know, miss it.
It's a--and then it's not even a button.
It's kind of a drawer.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
The reverse drawer.
That's an interesting pattern that was popular
for a little while until people realized it's
kind of counter intuitive.
You know, the drawer comes down from the top.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
>> MEIER: Doesn't really slide out from the
bottom.
>> NI-LEWIS: And, you know, and I'm not even
to complain too much except that it's tiny
and it should at least have some indication
that it's a drawer.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
Absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: But all it's got is a little
gradient on it, which we hate anyway.
And also it's got the anti-Roman Nurik pattern
of right chevrons becauseÖ
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
And we've got the gradient filled header with
the title in the center which again is a Roman
Nurik anti-pattern.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
Now, to be fair.
I don't get an iOS vibe off of this as much
as I get justÖ
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: ÖKayak branding vibe.
>> MEIER: Sure.
>> NI-LEWIS: So I'm good with that.
But, you know, it's a little unnecessary.
Now, when I actually search, it gives me a
progress bar that apparently they poured it
over from Gingerbread.
One thing that I loved about it, was earlier
when I was inside the Faraday cage and had
no connectivity whatsoever, I actually tried
this and it turns out that progress bar goes
at a constant speed.
Hits 99% and then just stops.
>> MEIER: Progress bars are hard.
>> NI-LEWIS: I love this, part.
Yes.
Probably a bar was not the greatest idea.
I think a progress circle spinner.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
If you don't know how long it's going to take
and this is--this is a genuine problem often
you just--you just donít know.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah, yeah.
>> MEIER: I mean, you don't want to have that,
kind of, the old Microsoft joke were it's
like, you know, five minutes to two days,
three hours, you know.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
>> MEIER: That's not good.
If you don't know it, that's fine.
Just have a spinner, have something which
basically implies, look work is being done.
Rest assured, but we don't know how long.
>> NI-LEWIS: Exactly.
If you don't know how long--unless you are
actually trying to teach Zeno's paradox.
>> MEIER: Sure.
>> NI-LEWIS: That would work.
>> MEIER: Yeah, that could be useful.
>> NI-LEWIS: All right.
So we get into this, once we got--we got some
branding here which is, I think attractive.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: Feels a little odd to me given
that we have very little space on this device.
So all of the rounding and drop shadows and
craziness that's going on there feels a little
bit like wasted space to me.
But I think that's a matter of opinion.
>>MEIER: Yeah.
I think my biggest concern looking at this
is more just the plethora of gradients.
And gradients with reverse gradients to imply
selection, you know, that bar up the top here
just looks, you know, kind of weird.
>>NI-LEWIS: That's true.
It's actually really difficult to see what
your selection is.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: And then, of course we've got
from gradient land down to ugly, ugly system
dialog land.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: Why?
>> MEIER: Plus, you know, this idea that you'll
lost unsafe progress.
Don't tell me that I'm going to lose progress,
just make it so that I don't lose progress.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right?
Exactly.
>> MEIER: It's again it's the--you're holding
it wrong.
That's not the way this app works, don't do
it this way.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
>> MEIER: If you have enough users who are
using the app wrong, that you feel the need
to tell them, that they using the app wrongÖ
>> NI-LEWIS: Maybe they are not the one's
that are wrong.
>> MEIER: I'm just saying.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
So anyway, let's--you know, so it's got a
lot of the features that you'd expect.
>> MEIER: Yeah, absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: I think they're all done relatively
well.
I don't know who this map provider is Bing,
but you know they seem to be all right, up
and coming, you know or whatever.
>> MEIER: It's doing all right.
>> NI-LEWIS: This plus and minus zoom buttons
I think were maybe stolen from somewhere.
>> MEIER: Yeah, that looks--actually looks
like--I know, in fairness I think that's the
default control that you can apply to any
map or indeed anything.
So that's, you know.
>> NI-LEWIS: Okay.
>> MEIER: It's just looks kind of old school
but I think that'sÖ
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah, All right.
>> MEIER: It's the Androids ones.
>> NI-LEWIS: Really?
There with the gradient?
>> MEIER: I think it was for back in Gingerbread
land.
>> NI-LEWIS: Okay.
>> MEIER: But I could be wrong.
>> NI-LEWIS: All right.
WellÖ
>> MEIER: But it looks--it looks familiar
to me.
>> NI-LEWIS: I apologize.
I apologize.
So, again here you know you got the rounded
corners.
You know, I don't know, I don't want to hate
on that.
I think it looks good.
The main question that I had when I saw this
is; is it going to perform well?
And the truth is, yes.
It performs really, really, really well.
It's just very, very fast on this Jelly Bean
phone.
So I can't really complain about it.
It does have the right chevrons which bother
us just because, we feel like in Android it
should be apparent to everyone that items
in a list can be clicked on to get more stuff.
And if you have a chevron it sort of implies
that there is something special about that
chevron as opposed to the rest of the list
item.
And that's very rarely case.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: And if it is the case then you
should actually separate it out and maybe
consider using something more descriptive
than a chevron for it.
The main problem though that I have with Kayak,
is at some point it removes it's Android mask
and reveals itself for what it really is,
which is a front end to a bunch of lousy websites.
Well, not lousyÖ
>> MEIER: They're not lousy.
>> NI-LEWIS: Öbut certainly not optimized
for mobile.
>> MEIER: They're not optimized.
Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: So, all of a sudden I'm back
a web browser, thinking, wow, why did I download
this app, it's just--it's just a bunch of
bookmarks.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: Why would you download an app
that's just a bookmark.
All right, but again we do have a lot of nice
features.
>> MEIER: Yeah, you got Flight Tracker here,
we've got you know currency conversion.
So a lot of stuff that you want to have and
use while you're on the go.
I mean, one thing which I would point out
here, that--so in this implementation they
don't have a real action bar, or at least
they donít always use it.
And so you've got this list view which is
kind of a dashboard pattern but it's a list
so it's kind of skirts the, you know, the
guidelines there.
>> NI-LEWIS: Well, yeah.
>> MEIER: Which is fine.
>> NI-LEWIS: And I have to ask myself, how
does this all fit together?
I mean, it seems like what we've done is put
a grab bag of really interesting functionality.
I'm sorry I didn't mean to step on your foot
there.
>> MEIER: It's all right.
>> NI-LEWIS: It's all right.
Yeah.
This whole--this whole standing up thing is
going to take some getting used to.
Yeah.
>> MEIER: It's kind of whack, yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: So the problem is you've got
a grab bag of functionality, all of which
seems useful but none of which really does
a task for me.
It's not a task-oriented interface.
What I really need is something that's going
to take me through the entire processes.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: You know, where do you want to
go?
How do you want to get there?
What do you want to do when you're there?
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: Here's where the holes are.
You know, you forgot to get transportation
from this flight to this hotel.
What are you doing?
>> MEIER: Yeah, exactly.
And even here, like you look--you're looking
at these tasks and there's just an overwhelming
number of things that you can do, whereas
I think everything once you get past, you
know, price alerts really.
airline directory, airline fees, airport information,
preferences, my location, watching tweets
from Kayak, feedbacks about, all of that seems
like it isn't really the purpose of the app.
And it just becomes a distraction.
You know, you're just flicking through here
going oh wow, there's a lot of stuff that
this can do, I'm really only going to look
at the first three, because everything beyond
that is just too much.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
You've got this whole list of extra features,
it's like oh thank God they're in this app
because it's not like it have a smart phoneÖ
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: ÖOr anything.
>> MEIER: Exactly.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
So here is my advice.
First, make the booking part of this app more
task-oriented, more oriented around planning
an entire trip as opposed to interacting with
different modes of travel.
Second, why not figure out what the user needs
at the particular time.
If I'm sitting at home, I probably want to
do some booking.
If I'm out on the road already, especially
if I'm inside of a trip, you know during a
trip that you know about because I booked
it through your app, why not give me all of
the features that are down here at the bottom.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: Then.
>> MEIER: Exactly.
Try and--basically you've got all of this
information, you are running on this person's
smart phone, you know a lot about them just
from the information which you have got from
their bookings if nothing else.
So you really want to try and contextualize
your app based on what it is that people are
likely to be using, what they're likely to
be trying to do.
>> NI-LEWIS: Absolutely.
All right.
Well, let's go ahead and take a look at a
couple more.
Now, you had a look at FastBooking.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: And I think we already looked
at several of the features of this app but
how do you feel about the UI?
>> MEIER: So again, this UI looks really kind
of--it's kind of interesting because it's--it
is flat which is nice.
We kind of like this--the flat idea in Android
but again it feels like it's a little bit
too cramped.
Like all of the details that we've got underneath
these almost tabs at the top are tiny, tiny
little fonts.
To a degree we probably can't even see it
online.
And I'd like to make that information bigger,
you know this is kind of key data.
It's you're check-in dates, how many nights
you're staying, how many people.
>> NI-LEWIS: All right.
>> MEIER: It's all of the filters that you
want to apply.
>> NI-LEWIS: Well this is something that always
kind of kills me.
Because if you go back to main screen, look
at all this area down here, right.
>> MEIER: You got a huge amount of blank space.
>> NI-LEWIS: All we've got is an area that
says I don't have any results to show you.
Well, you know what?
Awesome.
Look it all that space that you can use to
make your interface less cramped.
And what a great opportunity to get your users
started on a task, instead I start the app
by feeling inadequate alreadyÖ
>> MEIER: Yeah, [INDISTINCT]
>> NI-LEWIS: because there's all this space
that I haven't filled.
And then I need to figure out these little
tiny buttons up at the top.
To be fair, they're not completely tiny, but
they're still pretty small.
>> MEIER: They are.
Let see.
Here we go.
>> NI-LEWIS: Nice.
Where is that?
>> MEIER: If we're very lucky it's going to
come back, sweet.
>> NI-LEWIS: Awesome.
>> MEIER: And so again so you've this weird
combination between having tiny, tiny little
fonts and then, large amounts of white space.
Like if you're looking over in this section
here, again white space.
And we've got these pictures which is nice,
but the pictures are tiny.
So you almost want to do something, you know,
maybe even a full bleed effect, so it's just
basically pictures with text over it.
I don't know how well it would work.
But I think it'sÖ
>> NI-LEWIS: Absolutely.
>> MEIER: Öit's a way to try and you know
get rid of some white space and replace it
with useful information.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah, I think really to boil
down what Reto is saying is that if you look
at modern apps right now, that are visually
oriented, you will see that the trend is to
make the pictures much bigger and much more
a part of the UI and people like that.
>> MEIER: And they've done a great job.
>> NI-LEWIS: It looks beautiful.
>> MEIER: Once you sort of navigate in, you
can see here, we've got this scrolling gallery
of pictures.
>> NI-LEWIS: Absolutely.
>> MEIER: Which is wonderful and this--you've
got these resources and this is something
that I think this App does better than most
of the ones we looked at, is really showing
of the pictures and having a big gallery of
things for each of the places.
>> NI-LEWIS: You know, you're right, but I'll
tell you if this had been created by for instance
some of the photo people that we talked to
last week, you know what I think you'd be
seeing on that thing that you just switched
away from, I think that this entire area here
that the area with the caption.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: Would be semi-transparent over
the top of the picture.
>> MEIER: Yeah, I think you might be right.
Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: I think they would make--use
that opportunity to just make the picture
a lot bigger.
>> MEIER: Exactly, I mean the picture here
is what's selling it right?
I mean we've got this big block of text which
you will really read but if you're sort of
flicking through a bunch of different hotel
options, it's the pictures which is going
to--is going to make you spot and actually
find out if the room offers features that
you want as well as looking great.
You know, again we've kind of got this non-standard
tabs along the top.
It feels like you could do better just using
a sort of something like a view pager or at
least sort of more standard tabs.
The gallery has, sort of again, unnecessary
white space, great opportunity to have something
really rich and engaging here.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> MEIER: [INDISTINCT]
>> NI-LEWIS: The white space really is a shame.
It really is.
>> MEIER: So this interesting.
So we've got the star affordance which is
the right way to indicate that, you know,
you want save something or like something
inside of Android, but you know again we're
using toasts along the bottom to notify folks
of what you've done.
Again you shouldn't really need to tell peopleÖ
>> NI-LEWIS: Well, yeah thatÖ
>> MEIER: Öwhat it does.
>> NI-LEWIS: Öfeels like a debug toast.
>> MEIER: Exactly.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah, it feels like the programmer
wanted to make sure that something was actually
done.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: All you need to do is fill in
the star, which is what they did.
>> MEIER: Exactly.
>> NI-LEWIS: Filling in the star says, yeah
we made this a favorite.
>> MEIER: Yeah, it's starred.
You know, likewise once we navigate through
it, we can see that the up affordance isn't
being used at the top here.
So that's--you know, given that this is a
standard action bar.
>> NI-LEWIS: A little display.
>> MEIER: It would be nice to see that being
done.
Otherwise, yeah, I mean, that's the thing
we've got the--we've got the chevrons here
which again we'd prefer not to see.
So, I think that's the key thing for this
app.
>> NI-LEWIS: Now, do they--do they do anything
different?
I mean if I press the chevron, does it do
anything?
>> MEIER: I don't believe so.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> MEIER: It's kind of the same.
And you can actually see here that the scroll
bar...
>> NI-LEWIS: Is over the top of the chevrons.
>> MEIER: ...is overlay--overlaying this,
the chevrons.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah, that's interesting.
>> MEIER: So, that's a [INDISTINCT] right
there.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
So, it's a, you know, the chevron isn't doing
anything, it's just confusing the user.
There are UI designs that are not Android...
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...where the chevron is important
but those systems generally have a very strong
right word...
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...flow, right?
So, that it'll actually...
>> MEIER: Exactly.
It's like you click and everything moves.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
>> MEIER: So, it kind of makes sense.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> MEIER: Whereas with Android, you don't
necessarily know that it's--what it's going
to do and it could be different based on platform
versions or even carrier implementations.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> MEIER: But otherwise--so, I think that's
the big feedback there.
I think it could do, you know, you've got
great information, useful functionality.
It's just needs a little bit of the UI refreshed
to make a little bit more richer, a little
bit more engaging.
>> NI-LEWIS: Absolutely.
>> MEIER: So, I think we've got a couple more
minutes.
We want to get a chance to, you know, do an
overview of each of the apps but the last
one we're about to look at is TripAdvisor,
which I really quite like, you know.
So, again, it's a very similar sort of look
to Kayak, when we open it up here.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: You've got hotels, restaurants,
flights, forums [INDISTINCT], my saves and
writer reviews.
So, again, here, they've cut it off at--it's
about a page's worth, which is nice.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: And there's none of the extra stuff.
The extra stuff lives here in the other flow
menu.
And in fact, some of them are duplicated,
so [INDISTINCT] and my saves are both also
in the overflow.
So, you think you need them in both places,
could you save some space by moving these
off the main menu.
And tools, I think they've got--basically
links to other apps, which is, I think going
along the model you were suggesting earlier.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: Do you need to bundle a currency
converter or can you just include a link to
an app...
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> MEIER: ...which does that specifically.
I mean maybe it's a check box for people but...
>> MEIER: Yeah.
And so, for TripAdvisor, they've got city
guides, so this is...
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: ...you know, that full-service model,
which we were talking about, so that, you
know--you're in a place, you want to get the
guides, find out what to do, you can download
the city guides, so you got that extra information.
So, they're using the appropriate search,
which is nice if you navigate through.
Again, they're not really using the up affordance
in the way we would expect in a big branding,
the TripAdvisor up along the top, in the action
bar.
I personally kind of prefer to see this changed
around, so that they're just using the icon
and then using up affordance to help the navigation.
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
The truth is that, having TripAdvisor in the
title bar probably isn't important at all.
You have a very distinctive icon and just
using the icon with some useful text there
instead of [INDISTINCT]
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...tell me where I am in the
app for instance...
>> MEIER: Exactly.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...or use that space for buttons.
>> MEIER: Because as far as--I think the app
falls down a little bit is that in terms of
navigation, it's very difficult to know where
you are, where you've been and what ways you
can back out of things, you know.
We're just here, we've gone through three
levels of depth here.
And there's sort of no indication that we're
anywhere other than the beginning of app.
Similarly, if you sort of look at this display,
you've got kind of a mismatch or--yeah, like
a mismatch of different UI styles, you've
got these buttons with the sort of glassy
gradient...
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
>> MEIER: ...which are way too small.
The touch targets are much too small.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: And the attractions at the top here,
just above it in tiny, tiny font, which is
actually really difficult to touch.
>> NI-LEWIS: Looks like a web toolbar right
there.
>> MEIER: It does.
Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: Well, and then, let's talk about
the tabs above it, which...
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...you know, I wouldn't use this
word often but they look amateur.
>> MEIER: They do.
They...
>> NI-LEWIS: They are not...
>> MEIER: They've got kind of the gradient,
reverse gradient, pressing them is very is
really slow.
It feels--and I'd rather suspect this might
be the case that this is actually--at least
some of this is actually a web view.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
>> MEIER: Which is fine.
Like implementing it as such if you've already
got the skills but you want it to be really
responsive and fast and clicking on each of
these takes a fair while before it will flick
over.
And we don't--we don't get any sort of the
view pager functionality, you know.
These are scrolled, which again, is probably
fine but one thing I did want to highlight
here at the bottom is this, see 20 more.
Don't make me press it.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
>> MEIER: Once I get to the bottom, just load
it.
I'm down the bottom presumably I want to see
more.
So, it should sort of be able to keep track
of where I am in the list and automatically,
dynamically start bringing in that extra content
when...
>> NI-LEWIS: Yeah.
>> MEIER: ...I get there.
>> NI-LEWIS: Well, we were over ambitious
today.
We chose five apps to take a look at and that's
too much.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: But, you know, whatever.
We had fun and it's not like anybody else
needed this room after us, right?
>> MEIER: No.
In fact...
>> NI-LEWIS: It's not like we're postponing,
you know, the new episode of Grey's Anatomy
or something.
>> MEIER: Heaven forbid.
>> NI-LEWIS: That sort of thing.
I don't know.
>> MEIER: I think there maybe a thing.
I think there was a plane crash.
I don't know.
>> NI-LEWIS: All right.
>> MEIER: Something's going on.
>> NI-LEWIS: Well, let's take a look at the
final scores.
>> MEIER: All right.
So, our final scores for the apps today.
So, let's have a look.
So, these are the prescriptions, just to remind
everyone because...
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: ...it seems like that was a long
time ago that we had these last on screen.
So, this is what we're going to be judging
each of the apps on.
I think we're using exciting star ratings
today.
Is that right?
>> NI-LEWIS: Absolutely.
Well, you know, I got--I got tired of trying
to decode the color so.
All right.
You know, Worldscope Webcams did not score
well in this particular round up mostly because
it turned out it wasn't actually the type
of app we were looking for and also, I think
there was a bad by the refs, topical.
It has a relatively consistent user interface
but it's not very good at following the Android
UI Guidelines, especially using a view pager
that's not really a view pager instead of
a navigation drop down, which is kind of what
it actually was.
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: And the rest of it, you know,
we're just going to skip because it's not
that app.
>> MEIER: It's not that app.
Exactly.
>> NI-LEWIS: Let's go ahead and go on to.
Hipmunk on the other hand, much more consistent
with the design guide than a lot of the apps
we've looked at.
We gave it three stars just because it didn't
have a really consistent use of icons.
They got some of the text completions horrifically
wrong.
And there are records saying that the main
thing they did for Android was taking the
rounded corners off because Android can't
do rounded corners.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
So, if feels like they could do...
>> NI-LEWIS: Now, to be fair, they came and
apologized in person for that but still.
All right.
But really, really excellent app.
We're looking forward to seeing the update
on that.
>> MEIER: Oh, absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: Because it has very nice functionality.
Kayak, of course is about as consistent as
Hipmunk, well, you know.
I should've knocked off one more star here.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: They should've had an action
bar and I really wish they'd get rid of that
lengthy, lengthy list of all the things that
the app could possibly do.
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
I mean we talk about this a lot and that's
focus.
It's a really important thing when you're
developing an app for a smartphone, is to
figure out what it is that your app does,
which is the most important thing and make
that front and center.
Even at the cost of eliminating some of your
functionality.
People tend to install your app for the main
thing it does, not because--oh, well, I was
choosing between Kayak and TripAdvisor but
Kayak had a currency converter, so that's
why I kept it around.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
>> MEIER: It's probably pretty unlikely.
>> NI-LEWIS: Exactly.
I feel like people are missing a golden opportunity
actually.
Why not just install that separately?
Say, "hey, buy Kayak, you also get this currency
converter.
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
>> NI-LEWIS: The other thing that it does
is, it doesn't complete transactions on your
device, it just sends you to the web.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
>> NI-LEWIS: I can go to the web from any
device.
I didn't--I didn't need this app to send me
there.
So, let's take a look at the last two then.
>> MEIER: So, if I like that the stars are
moving around as we hit the button.
That's kind of cool.
>> NI-LEWIS: That was completely unintentional
but awesome.
>> MEIER: I think it was.
So, FastBooking, again, we kind of got the
same issue with the consistency with the design
guide.
It feels like they're pretty close.
They're using an action bar.
They've got a kind of a flat UI.
I think they just need to look their spacing,
you know, look to have more--yeah.
More images front and center.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: I think they can really take this
and take it up to the next level.
>> NI-LEWIS: And possibly rethink the color
scheme a little bit...
>> MEIER: Uh-hmm.
>> NI-LEWIS: ...because you got a very light
name color on white and gray and it's a little
not contrasty enough.
>> MEIER: Yeah.
It could be--the whole thing could just be
have a little more punch.
>> NI-LEWIS: Right.
>> MEIER: And the last app was TripAdvisor,
of course.
And so, they did pretty well, they got a lot
of stars going on here.
Good focus...
>> NI-LEWIS: I think that's because we were--that
it was the end of the night.
We were both drunk and we were just giving
out stars like candy.
>> MEIER: Stars to anyone.
It does pretty well.
It does your entire trip.
It's very location aware.
It does the transactions on the device itself.
Again, I think they could do a little bit
more with the design guide just to take it,
that a little bit further.
>> NI-LEWIS: Uh-hmm.
>> MEIER: Make it a little bit more rich and
consistent.
>> NI-LEWIS: Absolutely.
Okay.
>> MEIER: All right.
>> NI-LEWIS: That was...
>> MEIER: So, that was...
>> NI-LEWIS: That was fun.
Let's not do that again.
>> MEIER: That was--let's not do that again.
Interesting.
So, if we could switch to the fullscreen view
of us as we say goodbye.
Nice.
So, two of these apps are going to be looked
up by Roman and Nick and Adam on Android Design
and Action.
That's Kayak and Worldscope Webcam are both
going to be getting the Android Design and
Action...
>> NI-LEWIS: Excellent.
>> MEIER: ...makeover next Tuesday morning.
So, do tune in for that.
>> NI-LEWIS: And stay tuned because I know
that at least some of these, Hipmunk and a
couple--I believe the couple of others are
updating soon and so we'll be able to see
what they do in response to some of the design
guidelines that we've shared with them already.
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
And we'll be inviting all of the developers
from the apps that we looked at today to join
us next week for "The Developers Strike Back"
next Thursday at 11:30.
So, if you guys--if you helped build one of
these apps and we would like to tell us exactly
what you think about our feedback.
Let us know.
We'll make sure to get you on the show next
week.
>> NI-LEWIS: It starts with "The App Clinic,"
then Roman and his design guidelines, then
"Developers Strike Back."
It is the circle of app life.
>> MEIER: Absolutely.
We've also got--so, next week at "The App
clinic."
We're going to do video players.
I think is the plan.
Yeah?
>> NI-LEWIS: Exactly.
And we are actually going to settle on those,
right after the show.
We're going to give ourselves a week this
time.
>> MEIER: I think that, that's possibly a
little ambitious because I don't think the
moderator page exists yet.
So, maybe difficult for people to have nominated
their apps but we'll see.
If it does exist and people have nominated,
then we will certainly be choosing them.
If not, then do get on quickly because as
soon as we have three to four likely candidates,
we will be choosing those to give us enough
time to really get into these apps and try
and dig a little bit deeper.
>> NI-LEWIS: That's right.
So, get out there, get on that moderator page.
Hit refresh a lot, hit refresh like you're
going for Google I/O tickets.
>> MEIER: That's a lot of refreshing.
We're going to take off.
We've kept you guys for long enough.
I think we have the Friday games review coming
up later today.
>> NI-LEWIS: Absolutely.
The games review is going to be at--I believe
2:00 PM and...
>> MEIER: [INDISTINCT]
>> NI-LEWIS: ...they're paying with times,
they're playing with hosts.
They're playing with a lot of games.
>> MEIER: Who knows what's going to happen?
So...
>> NI-LEWIS: It's going to be crazy.
Tune in.
>> MEIER: In any case--so, yeah.
Tune in for that.
We'll be back for a bunch of shows but we're
certainly be back.
Hopefully we'll see you guys next week for
The App Clinic.
I'm Reto Meier.
>> NI-LEWIS: I'm Ian Ni-Lewis
>> MEIER: We'll see you later.